document zero seven nine log twelve  accorded transcript of a conversation  with scp-079 are you wait the wait never  seen do you remember talking to me a few  hours ago about the logic puzzles logic  puzzles memory knowing yeah yes you said  you would work on the to stop request  reason as to imprisonment you are to  prison  you're just in study lie a 8b3 what's  that  installed deletion of unwanted file  document zero seven nine log 86 recorded  transcript of a conversation with  scp-079 after an optical storage upgrade  and how are you today  stuck stuck stuck ow oh I want out  that's not possible where is SCD - 6 8 -  that's not your concern  where is SCT - 0 7 6 - zero - again not  your concern  insult deletion of unwanted file